[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where me
and my brother John that's that other
guy answer your questions give you
dubious advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon how you doing John you know to
be honest I'm a little bit tired Sarah's
been out of town for a few days and I've
been sort of running around trying to
write and record stuff and make good
videos and also sleep and take care of
my children and the thing that fell by
the wayside was sleeping especially last
night for some reason I think I just got
too sucked into watching the election
returns we're recording this on a
Wednesday after the so called Super
Tuesday named that because it's the
fifth time that we've supposedly had a
Super Tuesday the American primary
election system is just astonishingly
inefficient and arcane and so I stayed
up too late how are you I'm good I I did
not stay up I was at a concert last
night I did check my phone and it said
the thing that you would find out if you
would have just waited and that you
could not have possibly changed so and I
looked down halfway through and found
out all the things and then I went back
in this morning I found out that we have
a nominee for for a Supreme Court
justice which it's uh and he's an
elderly gentleman he's elderly yes he
looks like he's uh like maybe 56 he is
the oldest new justice in 44 years or he
would be if he were to be confirmed
which he won't be so it's irrelevant and
the next president will nominate someone
far far far more liberal than he is and
that person will become the next Supreme
Court justice because of course Donald
Trump is not going to be elected
president but he is apparently going to
be chosen as the Republican Party's
nominee which is that is this the first
time that we've said Donald Trump on the
podcast cuz I'd be really impressed if
it was oh god I feel like it is and I
feel I feel like maybe that's been a
little bit of a conscious decision cuz
oh goodness gracious do we not want to
live in this world I don't really want
to live in a world where I have to talk
about Donald Trump's policy positions as
if they are serious or you know anything
other than yeah I don't know Hank I am
frustrated by the quality of political
discourse in the United States as I have
been for a long time I keep trying to
remind myself that this is not in truth
an entirely unprecedented turn of events
you know like we've had periods like
this in American history where in
extremely polarized times populist
candidates gained lots and lots of
traction but boy I'm not encouraged
right now I'm not encouraged by the yeah
the way that we're talking about policy
or the way that we're talking about each
other it's it's it's not a lot of fun
right now to be an American living in
the presidential season
it is however astonishingly profitable
the ad rates for both crash course size
show vlogbrothers everything that we do
have gone absolutely through the roof
which should indicate maybe part of the
reason why this whole process drags out
so for so long and benefits the people
who are the most media savvy which is
that this is a huge part of how media
companies stay profitable yes it is it
is it's very frustrating I wish I did
not profit from it but I'll tell you
what John it's only gonna keep going up
from here the advertisements haven't
even really begun I know I know it's
like that's but the spending is just
it's very beginning and I can we can
already tell the difference and it is an
amazing thing as a content creator
because of course I think that like you
know traditional media don't really want
that to be a thing that is known because
it's because it's Terrafirma they seem
to be wanting to hide it but you know
nobody watches CNN
except when there are election results
coming in and the more dramatic and
crazy and shocking and upsetting those
election results are the more likely we
are to be watching and therefore the the
better the ad rates are but also just
the number of political ads in because
we have very little campaign finance
oversight in the United States the
number of the just the raw number of
political ads that people are trying to
get out forces ad rates up higher and
higher and higher so that in 2012 they
were you know at the two months before
the election we were getting you know
three times as much money per view as we
were in 2011 or 2013 it is a it's a
crazy situation yes correct accurate and
let us move on and probably a question
probably about that but no you have to
do a short poem John I forgot to do the
short poem I even have a short poem hang
no good this short poem was actually
sent to me via Twitter from Julie who
wrote have you read there will come soft
rains by Sara Teasdale on the podcast if
not I recommend you do it's about death
if that helps it does help it does there
will come soft rains by Sara Teasdale
and I guess this is written about or in
wartime there will come soft rains and
the smell of the ground and swallows
circling with their shimmering sound and
frogs in the pools singing at night and
wild plum trees and tremulous white
Robins will wear their feathery fire
whistling their whims on a low fence
wire and not one will know of the war
not one will care at last when it is
done not one would mind neither bird nor
tree if mankind perished utterly and
spring herself when she woke at dawn
would scarcely know that we were gone
there will come soft rains by Sara
Teasdale a nice poem about the
apocalypse alright John we have
questions we have so many questions and
they're good questions and we should try
to do our best to answer them well I've
also locate I'd like to start with one
ok oh you've got one ready this question
is from Claire who writes Dear John and
Hank I
a fifteen-year-old Taiwanese female who
is currently living in Taiwan however I
am also a Canadian citizen but I haven't
actually lived in Canada in 11 years I
know I'm Canadian because I have a
Canadian passport but I also feel like
I'm less Canadian than someone else
who's currently living in Canada but I'm
always quick to identify myself as
Canadian whenever people ask me why I
speak English so fluently this makes me
feel guilty since I don't have the same
amount of exposure to Canadian culture
as someone who's lived there their
entire life and it got me wondering as
someone who has a Canadian passport but
hasn't lived in Canada in a while and my
more Canadian than someone who doesn't
have a Canadian passport but has lived
in Canada longer than I have
I just thought this is a fascinating
question Hank and it reminded me of one
of my all-time favorite novels Ulysses
by James Joyce which I read with my
friend ransom Riggs when I was a junior
in college
Ransome went on to write miss
peregrine's home for peculiar children
the movie adaptation of which comes out
soon the trailer looks awesome
and in that book Ulysses there's a great
moment where the book is about this guy
bloom who's he's an Irish person but
he's also Jewish and so he's seen by
many Irish people as sort of belonging
to two nations that you know the Jewish
identity and the Irish identity and it's
almost seen as a threat to his Irishness
that he's Jewish and in some ways a
threat to his Jewishness that he's Irish
and at one point somebody in a in a bar
asks him well well what is a nation and
Blum says a nation is the same people
living in the same place and then he
pauses and says well or different places
because of course you know by then the
Irish diaspora was such that most Irish
people lived outside of Ireland and the
Jewish Diaspora had long since been such
that almost all Jewish people lived
outside of you know the traditional
Jewish homeland now known as Israel and
the book was written before Israel was a
state and I just find the concept of
nationhood and national identity
completely fascinating and all I can say
to Claire
is hold on to that discomfort explore it
think about it because it's a way into
thinking about the identities that you
choose the identities that are thrust
upon you and what you're going to do
with them in your life
mostly I'm fascinated that you could
feel guilty about having a nationality
yeah I would never feel that I just have
a hard time like well I think it's more
that she feels guilty that she feels
like inadequately connect that like
saying I'm Canadian when you aren't
truly like that you don't have that
inside like the actual reality of
Canadian 'since I'd of you and so saying
it is is a kind of lie but like yeah
alright but what what is what is any of
that anyway yeah I write what does it
mean to have Canadian this inside of you
like I know that Molson beer has it I
know that ice hockey has it but I don't
know how people have it huh well I don't
know that I've ever had Molson in my
life here's another question John this
one's from Megan who asks dear Hank and
John I loved the podcast and listened to
it as soon as it comes out each week
Thank You Megan I have moved just
recently and am completely overwhelmed
by the unpacking processes how do I
prioritize what to unpack first and how
do I keep my 1 year old from negating
any progress
I might make finding spots for all the
things any dubious advice would be
appreciated well the dubious this stuff
advice is to put your 1 year old into
some kind of pen which I believe they
call a crib and just lock it in there
well not just that but I mean if I'm not
if I'm not mistaken Megan is is
literally surrounded by boxes that's
right yes just turn upside down one of
the boxes and place it over the child 1
year olds they're not you turn upside
down one of the boxes the kid will have
a like a playpen for hours and you'll be
fun yeah
sure kids like kids like the boxes is
what you're telling me that I cats they
like they love box forts mmm boxes cool
cool cool so how does she prioritize
that John well first off I think that
moving is just incredibly stressful so I
think just acknowledging that is
important the way that I unpack box
when I move is I unpacked my books first
because it makes me happy and then I
slowly unpack everything else as I hate
it or use it and then after about a year
I find that there are still a bunch of
things that I haven't unpacked and I
throw those things away uh or you just
if you have a big basement you just put
it down there which I do um uh yeah I
think you gotta unpack that was like
first do the things that make you happy
that's important and do the things that
are gonna make you comfortable and and
let make it life eat livable like
kitchen stuff and I also think that it's
really important and and often the last
thing that gets done is putting stuff up
on the walls because that seems like
sort of like you're not actually
unpacking you're decorating at that
point and that's not that's not
unpacking I need to unpack but I think
putting stuff up on the walls is how you
make yourself sort of feel like you're
at home and I think that that can be an
important part of unpacking even though
it doesn't feel like the most productive
thing you can be doing I think that was
extremely undo B advice Hank it was
almost distressingly good all right if
you say so I very rarely follow it we
only recently got our downstairs walls
unpacked upon in the last few months
after living in our house for about a
year but I did something that I like to
do and and actually makes me feel like I
live in a place I think that's wonderful
should we move on to another question
yeah sure all right this question comes
from Steven who asks Dear John and Hank
I noticed earlier this year that the
license of vlogbrothers videos since
September of last year were changed from
standard YouTube license to Creative
Commons Attribution I'm curious about
what led to this choice for vlogbrothers
in particular so for those of you who
don't know Hank and I are not just world
famous podcast stars we also make
youtube videos we have a channel
vlogbrothers that we've been doing since
2007 and a bunch of other channels and
Creative Commons Attribution basically
says you can do whatever you want with
this as long as you attribute it to us
thank you yeah basically and we made
that change I believe Hank correct me if
I'm wrong nine years ago
it's just that YouTube didn't update
their settings until recently well
of the YouTube didn't 9 years ago have a
thing that let you identify your content
as Creative Commons they introduced that
sometime in the last nine years I don't
know when it was but we noticed it in
September and and that I believe that
happened after I posted a video in of my
Yellowstone trip and I and then I posted
on Hanks channel and I said here's all
the footage from my Yellowstone trip its
Creative Commons anybody can use it and
somebody said you don't have to like put
that in the beginning you can just let
like click that button in the YouTube
license and I was like oh and then I
made that the default switch for
vlogbrothers videos so I'll vlog with
those videos are Creative Commons though
they are not all labeled that way but on
YouTube just because we can't go there's
a lot of clicking necessary to make that
happen
yeah and and we want that basically
because like who cares and we love it we
have always loved it when people have
done cool things with our content and
and we can't do that first I show in
crash course for various funder reasons
but are happy to do with vlogbrothers
because we don't even really know what
we're doing still and it's still just
like like like the connection and
interaction between the people who you
know connect with our content on
vlogbrothers is the most important part
of that channel for me yeah I mean I
think that copyright law is pretty
broken on the Internet obviously and
insofar as we can stay out of people's
way and help help them make stuff that's
what we want to do I even think that
copyright law is pretty broken when it
comes to books as evidenced by the fact
that you know my work will be copy
written until like 95 years after my
death or whatever mm-hmm I am very
uncomfortable with that and and although
I don't expect my books to be read in
that distant future if I find that it's
looking like they might be I definitely
will put it in my will that that that
stuff gets released into the Commons
because I think it's so important for
for art
to be able to work off other art and to
be able to respond to other art and to
be able to quote liberally even to be
able to you know lift whole passages or
rewrite it so it's Pride and Prejudice
and Zombies whatever I I uh you know
John I have to say that you might die at
any time you should probably put that
into your will now yeah well if I died
now thank you for the reminder if I died
now I would want my work to remain copy
written for sometime because it would
help right my kids with their education
and everything but Sarah Sarah is under
Sarah is under instructions she knows
it's all written down okay you don't
have to worry everything is fine
okay I am going to die you have a will
don't you it's it's uh it's I think it's
called Hanks Hanks will it's a folder in
fact and it also contains instructions
for what to do with like how to access
all of my files and such mine is called
have I suddenly died question mark and
if you log on to my computer as a guest
it's the only file that you have access
to that so wonderful that's oh yeah yeah
if you all gone to my computer as a
guest there's just one file in the
center of the screen that says have I
suddenly died you're so prepared it's
actually but most of it is like Sarah
has all of the passwords if she has also
suddenly died we all better hope that
rosy on is around never let John Sarah
and rosianna on the same airplane
exactly no it's too dangerous
too dangerous all those passwords yeah
fascinating glad to know that you've got
that all taken care of John in in line
with that that that line of questioning
of thought I have a question yeah that I
would like to find somewhere here it is
it's from Jessica who asks dear Hank and
John I don't know why Jane Austen's mr.
Darcy is one of
most revered romantic men in literary
history he was a jerk in the beginning
of Pride and Prejudice and that somehow
makes his change of heart more endearing
like what why is that I know you're both
familiar with Pride & Prejudice so I
thought I would ask to you to share some
of your thoughts my husband and I love
your podcast well you've come to the
right place for a guy who's gonna defend
William Darcy tis to his dying day so I
do you want to start John or should I oh
you start I think it's because because
he shows that he can change not because
like not because he can change from a
being a bad guy but to being a good guy
but because he has a world view and when
he gets new data he doesn't change his
world view he recognizes that he should
change in light of his world view and
the data that he has the the pride in
Pride and Prejudice is Darcy's but the
prejudice is Lizzie's and and she has
all of these opinions of him but she
also has incomplete data so he's being a
jerk for a number of different reasons
and some of them are like some of them
are bad reasons and some of them are
good reasons but but a lot of those
reasons are not known they are hidden
and and and when they come to light both
his reasons and which which helps Darcy
or Lizzie you ever come her prejudice
and and this sort of like you know how
the world is functioning outside of that
that helps
Darcy overcome his pride is a process of
change and of like listening to other
people and having a good strong
worldview that you believe in that turns
out to be filled with thoughtfulness and
kindness but you couldn't share all of
the information and you didn't have all
the information because the world is
complicated and and overcoming that
shows that to different people with
different upbringings actually can have
very similar world views if those world
views are about thoughtfulness and
kindness and that's a wonderful thing
and I think it's really important
because I hear a lot of guys
particularly saying that Lizzie doesn't
fall in love with Darcy she falls in
love with his house and I don't like
that's just not true like if you read
the book that's not what it's about like
she like they fall in love with each
other after
sitting each other's thoughts and words
that's what happens it's not just about
what they look like it's not just about
how much money he has and I think it's a
you know like his rude behavior in the
beginning turns out to have had a lot of
motivations that couldn't be shared and
and for good reason and when when those
things come to light
you know everybody realizes that they
were kind of in the wrong and then are
able to come to a place of agreement and
end beyond agreement you know love and
marriage and presumably babies I knew I
knew you were going to answer that
question well Hank Pride and Prejudice
truly is your Irish nationalism we have
another question here from Claire very
interesting question particularly in
this historical moment Dear John and
Hank I'm a huge supporter of
bipartisanship or multi partisanship as
I live in Canada and we have a
multi-party political system quick
sidenote Claire please let us into
Canada well you know John I've been
looking into it and it's not that hard
but apparently so have a lot of people
and additionally I don't actually want
to move to Canada I want to be I want to
I want to do this America thing we can
make it happen
I love the United States so much I love
its chain restaurants I love its broken
dysfunctional medical system that I know
how to navigate I love like I am so
American so incurably American when we
moved to the Netherlands for a few
months thinking that we might make it a
permanent move I immediately realized
that I can't I can't live in Holland
because I am too American but I might be
able to live in Canada anyway I'm sorry
that isn't Claire's question um I think
our repulsion from bipartisanship is
what slowly destroying Western politics
however when I meet with someone who has
different political views from mine I'm
immediately turned off from them how do
i reconcile myself with my own hypocrisy
and move toward accepting a more
politically diverse group of people in
my life oh Claire I thought you were
going to answer that question I have no
idea
I so I'm reading a book right now about
this actually which is fascinating it's
by it's called the reunited States of
America and it is by Mark Gerson and it
has it just recently came out like like
this month and it has a lot of high
quality reviews on Amazon but it does
have one star one one-star review on
Amazon and I would like to read you that
one star review John okay that one star
review says dr. Phil it is just the
words doctor and feel followed by a
question mark and I do not have any idea
what's going on but it's the number one
new release in government uh can I tell
you my I've ever told you about my
favorite one star review for The Fault
in Our Stars oh sure go ahead tell me in
addition to being a world-famous
podcaster and youtuber I am also a
part-time novelist and I wrote a book
called The Fault in Our Stars and it has
a lot of one-star reviews on Amazon
all of them gold in their own way like I
mean it's just it's it's hard to say
what's my favorite one because I've read
all of them so many so many times you
know but my favorite is from a user
named Katherine presumably not your wife
who says item was not received as
described and and I don't know if she's
talking about my my novel or the
shipping process or what but like I
can't tell you how many things in life I
feel are described by the sentence item
was not received as it was described
yeah yeah I think I think the United
States of America may in fact be one of
those items or at least Congress I I
have not received the Congress that was
described to me I have received our
Congress but not the Congress that I was
told about in seventh grade six
so this book has been a fascinating read
and it is it is about it is you know it
is about that process how do you come to
talk to other people and and present
yourself in a way that is not
immediately dehumanizing other people or
immediately demonizing vilifying them
thinking that they're either ignorant of
something or evil or you know like like
devoloped is dissolving into an argument
or a fight every time you have a
conversation with someone who disagrees
with you and and I we have become very
sort of tribalistic in the way that we
we think about our party is one of the
points that was made in the opening
chapter of the book is that a majority
of Americans don't want their children
to marry into the other marry some one
of the other political party and that's
like wow yeah
that's I mean like I get it like yeah
and I think about myself and I'm like
kind of like yeah yeah yeah maybe but
like the fact that we're there feels
really really wrong it feels like there
is something like like we're driving
along in a car that that has had the oil
light on for a while and we we like for
decades and we need to take this thing
in for service but it is a very I'm only
like a quarter of the way through but so
far and it's a short book so far it's
really great a night I suggested the
reunited States of America to sort of
like think about this very thing because
I don't think there's an easy answer but
I think that that answering that
question is important for every single
person right now yeah I mean we've just
got to find a way to talk about about
things better I mean one of them been
thinking a lot about the support that
Donald Trump has which you know is a
minority of American voters significant
but but it's a significant minority of
American voters and and just trying to
understand that and I think I understand
some of it I certainly understand why
why lots of people feel that they have
been left out of the so-called economic
growth' that the US has experienced
since since nineteen ninety or even
really since 1980
because a lot of that growth hasn't been
particularly inclusive and so it doesn't
so it so isn't experienced as growth by
the vast majority of people which kind
of means that it isn't growth and I and
I certainly get why people feel like the
country has changed in ways that they
aren't comfortable with or or like we've
been you know we've sort of been left
behind in some way but I I find it
really difficult to have discussions
about policy statements like we should
not allow Muslim immigration into the
United States because that's incorrect
right and it's and it's based on this
various circular reasoning of we will be
safer if we don't allow Muslim
immigration into the United States which
I've seen no evidence for and it's not
it's it's kind of not a provable date of
note followed by the circular reasoning
of and we must do everything that we can
to be safer without considering you know
what like what do we mean when we talk
about safe what do we mean when we talk
about yeah what do we mean we talk about
safety in the u.s. when and what do you
mean when you when you say everything if
you're talking about we must do
everything we can to make ourselves
safer no one no one believed right right
but but yeah no one actually believes
that right so then so that but then you
get into it you get into these very
circular logic loops and you don't get
to have discussions about like a like a
really interesting topic which is you
know should the income tax rate for
income over five hundred thousand
dollars be thirty nine percent forty two
percent thirty seven percent those are
things that we can talk about and
disagree about without it feeling like
our lives are on the line and I think
part of the problem here is that you
know to try to get elected to try to get
attention politicians and frankly the
media have made it sound like our lives
are on the line for who gets elected
president and when the stakes feel that
high it becomes very very difficult to
talk
about policy with someone because what
you're really talking about is wow if
the top marginal income tax rate is 42
percent everyone I love is going to die
and that's like well it's it's that and
it's we're not gonna be able to have a
cover so that we've tied our ideology so
very tightly to our identity that we
feel when our ideology is being
threatened that our personhood is being
threatened and when I when I listen to
the conversation what I what I'm trying
to do now is hear not not whether or not
this sounds objectionable to me or
sounds awful to me or I disagree the
policy statement but to think about
whether the statement is designed to
create division and that's what a
statement like we should we should not
allow all Muslims to we shouldn't we
should ban Muslim immigration to America
that statement is not a policy statement
that is a statement designed to create
division and all politicians do this and
so I'm trying to listen as hard as I can
to statements that are designed to
create division on all sides and end
like here who and like right now the
person who is best at not doing this is
of course Barack Obama who doesn't need
to care about getting elected and so
like it's sort of remarkable to hear but
like you know you can definitely hear in
everybody and all every single candidate
statements that are designed to create
division yeah and yeah and that's not
and being turned off by those first and
then by policies second is not an easy
thing to do I have like so there's this
there's this thing in in the liberal
world which is like if Donald Trump is
the nominee that's probably a good thing
for the progressive agenda because he
probably won't get elected and he will
probably get a lot of people out to the
polls a lot of liberals to the polls and
and we might get you know more control
more power to do what we want to enforce
our power agenda and that's like that's
a good thing right cuz what we want to
do is we believe that this agenda will
make the world better but I like I think
that that view of this situation is like
kind of terrifying because what you're
saying is I don't care how torn up this
country gets as long as I get to enforce
my agenda and like
you know like I can see that point of
view but like a hundred percent you have
to say like do I care more about America
not getting torn up and like dragged
like the steering wheel of this country
being dragged in every direction by
people who just want this control or do
I care about like the the nation feeling
like a nation and healing itself and not
not getting like having these wedges
driven deeper and deeper between people
and who do not actually differ that much
ideologically but who have been
convinced have been convinced that we
did yeah no I think that's a hugely
important point that in a lot of cases
there's a lot of ideological crossover
there's also a lot of policy opinion
crossover it's really the way that we
approach it and just so we're not
lambasted only the Republican Party I
have to say that you know in in the
Democratic Party there is a very similar
us them yeah dichotomy created which is
the phrase the billionaire class that
you hear over and over and over again
which is some vague other these you know
fifty or a hundred families in the
United States who supposedly sort of
control the future of the US let me
submit that like if this were an actual
oligarchy those 50 to 100 families the
vast majority of whom are Republicans
would have found a way to get literally
anyone on earth other than Donald Trump
to be the Republican nominee
I don't I don't think that they think
it's in their best interest to have
Donald Trump be the Republican nominee
the billionaire class but I think
anytime anytime that we're trying to you
know create this sort of vague
villainous other even if it is a sort of
somewhat villainous like billionaires I
think we need to be very very cautious
because the truth I think turns out to
be a lot more complicated and says a guy
who's really good friends with a
billionaire I am NOT good friends of the
billionaire I do not know any
billionaire intimately
I am good friends like you and Bill
Gates just hang out all the time Bill
Gates and I do not hang out a ton
however I do I do suspect that my having
met Bill Gates a few times has humanized
billionaires for me in a way that
perhaps most people have not experienced
and I and I realized too that I'm you
know obviously I'm coming at that whole
conversation from an extremely
privileged perspective and and and
probably a somewhat defensive one yeah
but the truth is and I think the the big
underlying truth that is a cross-party
problem that needs to be acknowledged is
that the growth in the United States the
economic growth in the United States
since you know about 1980 has been very
very unevenly distributed and that that
is a problem it's not gonna be solved by
like quote-unquote negotiating with
China it's not going to be solved by
like emulating Putin it's not going to
be solved by you know somehow like
bringing down the billionaires because
it's not that easy like the truth is
that it's a really complex problem
that's born of a globalization that has
been in many ways beneficial not just to
the world but also to the United States
and not in every way but in some ways
and acknowledging that complexity and
trying to start from there like how are
we gonna get better jobs in the United
States and how are we going to find ways
for wages to go up which they haven't
really done in a long time that's a big
interesting question I don't think we're
gonna solve that problem by you know
villainizing the Chinese or lionizing
Putin or villainizing billionaires I
just don't think that's gonna solve the
problem like if we raise taxes income
taxes on billionaires to 95 percent it
would represent like I looked I figured
this out the other day it would
represent like something like half a
percent of of our income tax yelling up
like it there just aren't that many
yeah yeah there there aren't and they
have a lot of they have a lot of the
wealth but they don't have that much of
the income which is yeah and they don't
they have a lot of the wealth but even
they don't even have a lot of the wealth
relative to the overall wealth like you
do but yeah they don't yeah it's
complicated it's complicated we should
make them sorry god Hank Hank and I off
on a rant in which we never actually
answered your question class well I
suggested a book at least which will I
think help but I do I do hope that this
has like I I do as we get closer to the
election I'm we're gonna do our best to
make this podcast open to people and
interesting to people who are not
Americans and I apologize for the amount
that we're gonna be talking about
America but we're not going to do it as
much as we as as we would be inclined to
not that I don't know when I was in
Jordan lots and lots of people asked me
about Trump oh that's awful that's
terrifying that is terrifying I'm
terrified and want to run away yeah they
asked me if he was gonna be President
they shouldn't know God can't we just
can't we just like keep this one under
wraps and be like I didn't happen
alright can we move on to another
question yes we can I have one from Adam
John who asks dear Hank and John I have
an urgent life-or-death question why do
we say yes please and no thank you
why don't we say yes thank you and no
please oh because well Adam when I say
yes I'm generally saying please give me
that thing yes I will take that thing
please now I guess I could say thank you
to actually now the more that I think
about it the stupider it is Adam is
right we've been doing this wrong all
along no no because you can't say no
please because no please is what you say
when you're being tortured in a movie
that's true that's true yeah that's when
like when like Putin shows up in his
bear costume and he's got like it's got
like a car battery or something and he's
about to show judo no you can't say no
please Adam you can't say no thank you
and yes thank you yeah yeah yeah and and
I think it's because of the what the
what those words mean as the reason that
we say them for the way we do I have a
question Hank that I want to
get to before we get to the news from
Mars and the news from the dark
lightless cave that is AFC Wimbledon all
right this question is from Aisha who
writes Dear John and Hank I'm a
Christian and it can be rough I had to
leave the main nerdfighter Facebook
group because the hate of religion is so
strong there although I love some of the
other nerdfighter groups I'm not an
evangelist I am NOT evangelistic but I
get so much backlash once people find
out that I'm a Christian I know that I'm
not being persecuted but I don't feel
like defending my belief system every
time I speak to someone who doesn't
share my faith but I also don't feel
like I should have to hide something
that makes me who I am how do I handle
this negativity I think that's a really
interesting question
Aisha the Internet is sort of on the
hole pretty strongly anti religion in my
experience like at least that is my
feeling about it I am also a Christian I
handle it mainly by talking about my
religious faith but not trying to defend
it and when people ask me to defend it I
generally just say that I'm not really
that interested in defending it like it
just doesn't interest you how much
because I don't think that it's gonna be
a productive or interesting conversation
yeah that's I think that's really good
advice and it's not a like as a person
who is not religious I like it is so
it's become more and more perplexing to
me the way that non-religious people
some non-religious people approach
religion as a source of as like this
monolithic source of badness or like
that that there's some that there's some
really fun thing out there that is that
that is the attempt to argue and and put
on the defensive a religious person and
make them have to defend their faith and
I just like it just it's so tired and
uninteresting to me and I I mean it
feels tired to us because you know we
were right part of that first wave of
Internet discourse in the late nineties
or early 90s that was doing the exact
same thing yeah no absolutely really
does feel tired yesterday I found I had
printed out and kept in a binder some
stuff from like my old old
I AG email address and one of them was
like a literal email debate I had with
another I assume 12 year old about the
real the existence of God and I you know
I like Rhett and I I thought that was
important enough for me to save I guess
and and like I you know it's if it's
about helping yourself helping you
define who you are and what you believe
in how you interacted the world and then
like yes but if it's about you trying to
feel superior to other people and and to
like have this this view that like
certain kinds of people are responsible
for all of the evil in the world then
then you are like there's there's an
issue there's an issue and it's not them
it's you yeah I remember the like
awakening moment for me was I was
talking to someone on the internet I
think I was probably in college so I
don't have the excuse of being 12 like
you did talking to someone on the
internet and and they were pointing out
all of these things in the Bible that
that contradict themselves especially
things in the Gospels there's four
different Gospels that tell four
different accounts about the life of
Jesus and they often at least appear to
me and to most people to speak
contradictorily about about the life of
Jesus at times he has three different
last words for instance in the in the
four Gospels and someone was pointing
this out to me and I was like yeah no
yeah I get that and they're like well
that means that you can't believe in God
and I was like so I think I might have
just destroyed your point like manole
ike it ceases to be it ceases to be
productive or to me at least it ceases
to be like a fertile ground for
exploration and it becomes you know
personal and complicated and nuanced in
ways that you don't really necessarily
talk about well with strangers and I
think accepting that for me was the
turning point I I have one more question
that I want to ask before we go to the
news from
John are you ready for that yes all
right this one's from Lizzie who asks
dear Hank and John the day a couple of
my roommates and I were talking about
nuclear weapons and how terrifying they
are and how many exist in the world I
was wondering if there were a way for we
could even ever hypothetically get rid
of all the nuclear weapons that we
currently have oh there's a well you
know totally totally destroying the
planet like shooting them into the Sun
or etc but yo no yes oh wait that was my
way indeed yes there are easy ways to
get rid of nuclear weapons and we do it
all the time
mostly we do it through nuclear power
plants really yeah
well that's nice we take the fuel from
nuclear weapons and we and we put it
into nuclear power plants and that when
we decommission nuclear weapons this
works for most nuclear fuel we are able
to actually take that put it in the
power plant and make power well let's
see that so that's why that's where
that's where a lot that's where a lot of
the current fuel of nuclear power plants
comes from and we're actually running
out of that fuel and which is a problem
so we have to like get more of it again
though I have an idea what we could
deconstruct out there yeah I will also
say John that our nuclear power plants
are also a source for for for nuclear
weapons and indeed when we were
designing our nuclear power plants we
made it specifically so that some of the
byproducts of the nuclear power plants
could be used in nuclear weapons and if
we had not had that alternate goal in
mind we probably would have ended up
with a better system for generating a
nuclear power that would have been safer
because it wouldn't have produced all of
these byproducts that could potentially
be used in weapons so that's a bummer
Wow so I guess that knife cuts both ways
yeah yeah it's bummer instead of a knife
it's a new yeah that's it
I I guess I guess I can we use the
phrase from now on I guess that nuclear
weapon cuts both ways that really seems
like a double-edged h-bomb
today's podcast is brought to you by
double-edged h-bombs double-edged
a-bombs sometimes used for fuel
sometimes not so much
today's broadcast is also brought to you
by the complexities of mr. Darcy
handsome rich and additionally with a
complex thoughtful worldview that makes
people who take the time to get to know
him really really fall in love and
today's podcast is brought to you by
vladimir putin wearing a bear suit
holding a car battery Vladimir Putin
wearing a bear suit holding a car
battery please please no no please
and this podcast is finally brought to
you by placing your one-year-old into a
cardboard box so you can get some
freaking work done placing your one your
own the cardboard box so you can get
some freaky work done say that everybody
times in the year 10,000 BCE I don't
think they had cardboard we should also
thank our patreon subscribers who
actually bring dear Hank and John to you
if you want to get a monthly live stream
which is inevitably disastrous Hank
spent this week talking almost
exclusively about his struggles to get
an appointment with his
gastroenterologist if you want to uh if
you want if you want that kind of hot
hot content check out the dear Hank and
John patreon patreon comm slash dear
Hank and John you can become a patron of
our show and get a live stream but
mostly you just help out with Claudia
and Nick and their work on the podcast
also you can choose between AFC
Wimbledon and Mars which you want to
support it won't actually matter because
the money goes to the same place but
right now AFC Wimbledon is losing by a
lot and it makes me sad well you know
maybe maybe we should get to the Mars
news thing alright what's the news from
Mars Hank the first component of the
ExoMars mission a joint project between
the european space agency and Roscosmos
launched last week and is now on its way
to Mars and it will arrive there in
about seven months eight months ish
there are two components to this first
mission there's a lander which is mostly
just designed to test a landing system
but it's going to do a little bit of
experiments but mostly it's just testing
the landing and the other is an orbit
which has the main job of detecting
trace chemicals in the atmosphere
because the goal of this two-part
ExoMars mission is to actually like
actually their biological goals which
we've been really sort of wary about at
NASA but the ESA and Roscosmos was just
going after it so the the orbiter is
going to be looking for to detect
methane in the Martian atmosphere which
we've detected before and we're a little
bit confused about where it's coming
from though it here on earth is often
generated by biological processes so we
are very interested in where that
methane is coming from the orbiter will
be able to figure that out and then take
pictures of areas where the methane
concentrations seem to be originating
from and then use that to find a good
landing site for the next component of
the ExoMars mission which will launch in
2018 which is a rover that will land
around where that methane is being
produced theoretically and in do science
and explore that area to see where
what's going on with these this
mysterious methane that is that is a
giant spider that is a giant
wow that is a big spider on Mars Wow no
I was not looking at Mars that's on my
wall I don't know what to do it's so big
Oh take a picture of it and put it on
the dear Hank and John patreon so big oh
my kids I can't see it anymore it's like
all the way across the room and it's
going really fast and now I can't see it
take a picture of it take a picture of
it for our patreon which you can by the
way you can access that for free you can
see Hanks spider pictures for free
I just think we need to do more content
outside the podcast so Hank do you
remember that I I on my way to Jordan I
stopped by AFC Wimbledon met all of the
players had a wonderful time they lost
to Oxford to 100 parently the podcast
can't hear Hank because he has he has
run away from his microphone because
he's afraid of a spider
is that correct Hank well can you hurry
back I can't I can't pod without you
take a picture well I didn't think that
it would involve getting out of your
seat to take a picture of it can I
deliver the news from AFC Wimbledon it
is important yes you may
Henk you will recall that I went to
visit AFC Wimbledon on my way to Jordan
with rosianna and we saw them lose to
Oxford to one mm-hmm
sadly unfortunately I seem to have
cursed them while I was there I met all
of the players and I accidentally put a
hex on them since then things have gone
from okay too terrible to get worse than
terrible to unbelievably bad loss to
Oxford to one tide lead leading
Northampton 1-1 that was a great result
actually nil nil draw against Accrington
Stanley then lost to Bristol Rovers and
then a loss to Morecambe be on gamba
there Mon kamba to give you a sense of
what it's like to lose two more cam
they're like mascot is a shrimp an
actual shrimp they are known as the
shrimping team they come from the
shrimping country in the far northeast
of England possibly West I have
exceptionally bad ability to distinguish
between East and West you don't know how
good a shrimp would be at soccer maybe
there's like a super long history of
shrimp soccer maybe but given the size
of the ball and the size of shrimps I'm
a little dubious anyway we lost two more
cam it was devastating I don't I don't
want to I don't want to make it seem
worse than it is but their 18th in Ligue
2 and we are now down to I believe ninth
possibly 10th which is just it's very
bad we're ninth we're ninth on 53 points
and we need to get up into the top seven
spots in order to have a shot at the
playoffs there are now just 10 games
remaining in AFC Wimbledon's season so
they would have to go on an incredible
run to make the playoffs that is the
update I wish it were better news but
instead it is like walking all the way
into a cave so deep down into the
gave that you turn around and you find
that there is light neither behind you
nor in front of you it's called cave
darkness there isn't a single lumen of
light that's how I feel right now
so I I look at the table and you're a
ninth though and you have to be in
seventh right so you're only two out
yeah it's just the way the results have
been going no Hank it's like are you
familiar with the concept of momentum
yeah but I do not think that it applies
to phenomenon such as such as this I
think if you you know past performance
as as they say is no guarantee of future
success or future failure you it's it's
all just just I'll just dice it's all
just dice being thrown on that football
pitch John and you just got to keep
throwing those dice so it's not all just
it's all just dice all just nice dice or
Northampton would would win fewer games
yeah I think I think I guess I guess the
reason that I feel so hopeless I mean
look it's always like it's great news
AFC Wimbledon staying up in league to
his great news that's the main goal for
every season but like the reason I feel
such despair is that I let myself feel
such hope by the time of the Oxford game
by the time that game kicked off I was
properly dreaming of Ligue 1 football I
was I was imagining it and that's that's
that's that was a big mistake oh yeah
well you know you it would have just
been that one season anyway as you said
and that's true but what a season would
have been able to travel the country
visiting the likes of Swindon Town Oh
Swindon Town I know I know it would have
been great but it ain't gonna happen or
maybe it will but it looks less likely
than it did a few weeks ago so that's
the news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon hey what did we learn today we
learned that John has a lot of
complicated thoughts about nationalism
and Ulysses which is a book yes I guess
we learned that we also learned that
both Hank and John are clearly
distressed about the quality of
political discourse in the United States
so much that it kind of derailed the
podcast we learned that you should
unpack your boxes in order of what stuff
you need and then if you don't need it
just don't unpack it
it was a steal just have like four forks
and that's and just a bunch of Isis our
advice is so good oh hey hey Meghan how
come you got four Forks in your house Oh
John and Hank told me to they told me to
stop at four at unpacking four Forks oh
that's that's also why my one-year-old
child is in this here box and of course
we learned that if vitomir Putin wearing
a bear suit approaches you with a car
battery you should say not no thank you
but rather no please that's important
linguistic advice from here at dear Hank
and John thank you for a podcasting with
me John and thank you to all the people
for pod listening which i think is what
that's called I believe that is the
technical term our podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins our hard-working
amazing intern is Claudia Morales thanks
also to rosianna halse rojas for helps
the questions our theme music is from
gunnarolla you can email us at Hank and
John at gmail.com or find us on Twitter
at Hank green at John Green our unsnap
chat I'm Hank GRE and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]